المسؤول الصحفي للبنتاجون قال ان الدوريات
المشتركه مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال
سوريا والتي تستهدف عناصر تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه قل عددها بسبب تقليل القوات
الكرديه من تحركاتها في المنطقه خوفا من
زحف تركيا بري اللواء باترايدر قال ان
وزير الدفاع الامريكي سيتحدث الى نظيره
التركي
والعراق وتركيا نحو بتاكيد على ضبط النفس
البري مكاسبنا في مكافحه داعش للخطر والى
زعزعه الاستقرار في المنطقه
في تركيا
التي تحدث داخل حدودها قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه اعلنت عن مخاوفها من احتمال
غزوه تركيه لمواقعها في الرئيس التركي حدد
عملياته عسكريه في استهداف ما يعتبره
مواقع لحزب العمال الكردستاني قائد قوات
الديمقراطيه قال ان هناك تعزيزات جديده في
مناطقه تسيطر عليها الفصائل المتحالفه مع
تركيا مازلنا قلقين فنحن نحتاج الى
تاكيدات اقوى واكثر صلابه لوقفه تركيا لقد
اعلنت انقره عن نيتها وهي تستطلع الامر
الان تتوقف بدايه الحمله العسكريه على
طريقه تحليل تركيا لمواقف الدول الاخرى
العبد قال انه لم يطلب منه الانسحاب بحسب
اتفاق 2019 وان الاطراف المعنيه الولايات
المتحده وروسيا منشغلتين بالحرب
الاوكرانيين وانه سيرفض الانسحاب بكل
الاحوال وقال انه كان يامل بمساعده جويه
من النظام في دمشق في مواجهه الضربات
التركيه لكنه لم يعد يعتمد عليها لانها
ضعيفه